die kanzlerin das wort bitte ja meine
damen und herren ich möchte mich auch
entsprechend der konstruktion der
bundespressekonferenz als erstes dafür
bedanken dass ich eingeladen wurde und
hier der hauptstadt presse rede und
antwort stehen kann
ich möchte ihnen danken dass das trotz
und mit dem infektionsschutz möglich
gemacht haben und nicht nur die die hier
im saal sind herzlich grüßen sondern
auch die die uns außerhalb des saals
jetzt zu hören weil natürlich die
abstandsgebot hier auch gelten
ich bin heute zu ihnen gekommen weil mit
dem heutigen tag in deutschland die
einschränkungen des öffentlichen wie des
privaten lebens in kraft treten
die bund und länder für den monat
november beschlossen haben diese
einschränkung treffen eigentlich jeden
bürger jede bürgerin und deshalb ist das
natürlich auch ein sehr wichtiger tag
sehr viele von den bürgerinnen und
bürgern reagieren mit verständnis und
einsicht auf diese notwendigen
einschränkungen aber es gibt auch
zweifel skepsis ablehnung und deshalb
ist mir sehr wichtig an diesem ersten
tag noch einmal darzulegen warum wir uns
zu diesem schritt entschlossen haben
ich sage auch entschließen mussten und
was das ziel dieser einschränkung ist
ich glaube wir müssen uns immer und
immer wieder bewusst machen dass wir in
und mit der pandemie leben und dass das
nicht irgendeine eigenes ist sondern ein
sehr besonderes und sehr
herausforderndes ereignis man kann
vielleicht sogar sagen ein eigenes bier
ist es nur ein mal pro jahr 100 ich
hoffe dass das auch für die zukunft so
ist gibt und dass wir jetzt in den
wintermonaten sind oder im herbst und
der die wintermonate kommen das heißt
dass anders als im frühjahr und
schwierige monate bevorstehen bei
niedrigeren temperaturen dieses jahres
auch anders noch aggressiver reagiert
ich komme gerade aus dem chor oder
kabinett und wir haben uns dort im kreis
zuständigen minister auch wieder die
aktuelle lage klar gemacht die macht uns
sorgen an diesem montag 12 1097 neue
gemeldete infektionsfälle beim
robert-koch-institut das ist in etwa
eine verdreifachung in 14 tagen eine
verfünffachung seit mitte oktober
das ist exponentielles wachstum das uns
mit zunehmender geschwindigkeit auf eine
akute notlage in unseren krankenhäusern
zu laufen lässt und wir sehen das ja
auch an der zahl der korona patienten
auf intensivstationen die sich sozusagen
in den letzten zehn tagen auch wieder
verdoppelt hat von 1030 belegten betten
am 22 oktober auf 2061 belegte betten am
ersten november wir wissen auch dass die
zahl der auf den intensivstationen
liegen den patienten noch einmal
zeitlich verzögert zu der aktuellen fall
zahl ist das heißt die heute gemeldeten
fälle haben sich vor etlichen tagen
infiziert und die heute gemeldeten fälle
werden erst in 14 tagen überhaupt in den
intensivbetten statistiken sichtbar
werden dass das das heißt das was wir
heute an intensivpatienten sehen das ist
das was ich vor etwa zehn bis 14 tagen
abgespielt hat und weil wir sehr stark
steigende zahlen in den letzten zehn
tagen hatten werden wir auch weiter
steigende belegung der intensiv
kapazitäten sehen und zu sehen wie wir
näher und näher an die belastungsgrenze
des personals und der strukturen in der
intensivmedizin kommen das kann keine
regierung verantworten das will die
bundesregierung nicht verantworten
und ich persönlich will es auch nicht
das heißt also wir dürfen nicht zulassen
dass dieses diese schnelle verbreitung
des virus unsere gesundheitsämter immer
weiter überfordert schon bei den
derzeitigen zahlen ist es nicht mehr
möglich die kontakte jedes einzelne
nachvollziehen
und das heißt dass praktisch viele
menschen infiziert
durch die gegend laufen ohne gewarnt
worden zu sein insbesondere die die
keine symptome zeigen und das heißt dass
die sich wiederum daran sich wiederum
andere anstecken und weil diese
entwicklung so gelaufen ist weil viele
gesundheitsämter die kontakt nach
verfolgung nicht mehr schaffen haben wir
jetzt eine situation bei der in 75
prozent der fälle also drei viertel der
fälle die infektion nicht mehr
zugeordnet werden können das heißt man
kann nicht mehr sagen wo diese infektion
stattgefunden habe und deshalb müssen
wir wieder in eine situation kommen in
der die gesundheitsämter kontakten
nachverfolgen können sonst nimmt das
exponentielle wachstum immer weiter zu
und bei einer inzidenz von 150 oder 200
in einer kommune ist das nicht möglich
wir haben heute deutschlandweit eine
gemittelte inzidenz von 127,8
infektionen pro 100000 einwohner in
sieben tagen
wir müssen wieder in eine region von 50
infektionen sieben tagen pro 100000
einwohner kommen bis dahin können die
gesundheitsämter das einigermaßen
nachvollziehen
und das ist nun das ziel wieder in diese
region zukommen der maßnahmen der
nächsten vier wochen
sie sind hart das weiß ich und trotzdem
ist nicht mehr der zeitpunkt in dem wir
diese oder jene kleine variante machen
können oder einfach nur auf die regeln
hinweisen
wir wären dann halbherzig und das virus
bestraft halbherzigkeit deswegen haben
wir diese umfassenden einschränkungen
gemacht und es geht immer um die frage
weil wir wissen dass da ein enger
zusammenhang besteht zwischen der zahl
der kontakte und der zahl der
infizierten
das heißt wir müssen kontakte reduzieren
wo immer das möglich ist
das heißt als erstes home office zu
hause arbeiten wo immer möglich aber die
maßnahmen greifen dann tief in das
private leben ein keine urlaubsreisen
keine nicht unbedingt notwendigen
verwandtenbesuche keine feste und feiern
das freizeitangebot und die
kulturstätten werden geschlossen und zu
hause sollen sich
so wenig wie möglich menschen treffen
der aufenthalt im öffentlichen raum ist
beschränkt auf zwei ausstände sollten
diese haushalte größer sein als je fünf
personen in einer familie dann ist das
nochmal beschränkt auf maximal zehn
personen aber das eigentlich wichtiges
die 2 ausstände die zwei haushalte und
das bedeutet natürlich vier wochen lang
verzicht auf vieles was das leben schön
macht und das wissen wir sowohl die
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten als auch wie in der
bundesregierung
wir haben lange abgewogen ob es einen
besseren oder milderen weg gibt wir
haben ihn nicht gesehen und deswegen
haben wir diese regelung schweren
herzens beschlossen aber eben auch aus
überzeugung wir glauben dass sie
geeignet sind unser ziel zu erreichen
und sie sind erforderlich um die
kontakte zu reduzieren
die wissenschaftsorganisation haben
genau dafür ausgesprochen wir haben also
auch hier beratung gesucht und eine
massive einschränkung der kontakte
bedeutet entsprechend weniger
gelegenheiten zur ansteckung und wenn
wir das einen monat mit aller konsequenz
durchhalten kann das in dieser zweiten
welle ein wellenbrecher sein
das war's dann sind natürlich auch
zustande gekommen weil wir uns überlegt
haben was ist das allerwichtigste zum
funktionierenden in unserem land und das
sind nach unserer meinung eine
infrastruktur die im gesundheitsbereich
dasteht und pflegebereich krankenhäuser
pflege das ist den wirtschaftskreislauf
so weit wie möglich am laufen zu halten
und für uns waren das als lehre aus der
ersten welle der pandemie das
offenhalten von schulen und
kindertagesstätten wir haben immer
wieder gesagt sie müssen als letztes
denn überhaupt notwendig geschlossen
werden hat als erstes auf gemacht werden
das letzte mal war es genau andersrum
deshalb jetzt die bewusste entscheidung
dass wir diese kitas und schulen offen
lassen denn aber all diese kontakte
unabdingbar sind dann müssen andere
eingeschränkt werden und ob diese große
gemeinsame kraftanstrengung etwas bringt
im monat november
das hängt nicht nur von den regeln ab
sondern
vor allem auch davon ob diese regel
befolgt werden weil viele sich im
privaten leben abspielt weil viele
menschen sehr persönliche entscheidungen
treffen werden
ihn treffe ich ihn treffe ich nicht und
das im auge haben sind wir auf das
mitmachen und auf die akzeptanz und das
verständnis der menschen in unserem land
angewiesen damit das funktionieren kann
das heißt also jeder und jeder hat es in
der hand diesem november zu unserem
gemeinsamen erfolg zu machen
zu einem wendepunkt wieder zurück zu
einer verfolgbarkeit der pandemie und
wenn es das in den nächsten vier wochen
gelingen würde die ausbreitung des virus
zu bremsen dann schaffen wir uns die
voraussetzungen dafür einen erträglichen
dezember zu haben
natürlich weiter unter krone regeln so
wie wir sie jetzt ja schon seit vielen
monaten kennen aber wieder mit mehr
freiraum
wir haben heute im kabinett über die
wirtschaftshilfen gesprochen die die
angeordnet die die unternehmen betrifft
die jetzt schließen müssen
der finanz und der wirtschaftsminister
werden sehr schnell und unbürokratisch
handeln und bis zu zehn milliarden euro
zur verfügung stellen niemand ob
gastronomen oder fitnessclub leiter wird
mit seinem aus einnahmeausfall in diesen
nächsten vier wochen alleine gelassen
ich weiß dass viele restaurants
geschäfte und betriebe ja große
anstrengungen unternommen haben und uns
das pandemie bedingungen arbeiten zu
können und das sind vorkehrungen die
noch sehr wertvoll sein werden denn wer
nämlich wieder in einer etwas freie zeit
hinein gehen können aber im augenblick
wegen der 75 prozent nicht mehr zuordnen
waren infektionen und gegen der
absoluten notwendigkeit kontakte zu
reduzieren können diese hygienemaßnahmen
nicht ihre wirkung entfallen
und wir sind uns auch einig dass die
hilfen die kultur erreichen mit und
menschen die jetzt in diesem moment
wieder nicht auftreten können oder ihre
künstlich zeigen können die leiden
natürlich darunter und bringen für uns
alle für die ganze gesellschaft damals
ein opfer genauso wie die restaurants
bars und clubs auch die kulturszene
hatte ja mit viel viel
liebe und engagement möglichkeiten und
formen gefunden wieder arbeiten zu
können und wir wissen alle dass die
kultur für unser zusammenleben in der
gesellschaft existenziell ist dass sie
wichtig ist und für eine freie
gesellschaft central ist und umso mehr
schmerzt es jeden und auch nicht ganz
besonders dass wir auch hier kontakte
reduzieren mussten für den monat
november
es geht also nicht um das hygiene
konzept für diese oder jeder einrichtung
sondern es geht darum dass wir für die
gesamtheit aller kontakte in unserer
gesellschaft eine reduktion hinbekommen
die wissenschaftler sagen uns eigentlich
von 75 prozent aller kontakte und das
ist sehr sehr viel von 4 kontakten die
wir normalen zeiten haben drei vermeiden
und einen möglich machen
und wenn wir allein daran denken dass
schulen und kitas auf bleiben mit weit
über 10 millionen kindern dann ist das
schon eine große aufgabe
ich will zum abschluss noch etwas sagen
zu der korona warm-up die jetzt von 21,5
millionen menschen heruntergeladen wurde
si wir haben inzwischen von den
niedergelassenen laboren 152 von 165
angeschlossen
es wurden über diese waren app
inzwischen 257 millionen testergebnisse
übermittelt und 38.000 nutzer haben ihre
positiven testergebnisse dann weiter
vermittelt an ihre kontaktperson und
leider sind wir allerdings bislang nur
bei 60 prozent der positiv getesteten
die ihre kontakte auch weitergeben da
liegt noch eine große aufgabe auf die
wir immer wieder hinweisen wollen dass
wir hier noch mehr menschen dazu
ermutigen wollen wenn sie positiv
getestet sind auch die kontaktperson
anonymisiert natürlich zu informieren
wir haben im gegensatz zum früher einige
lichtblicke
wir haben mehr und besseres material
wir haben neben den pcr tests jetzt auch
die schnelltests die antigen
schnelltests zur verfügung die
den schutz von wohlhabenden gruppen also
von menschen die besonders
risikoanfällig sind für diese krone
virusinfektion wir haben bessere
medikamente noch keine durchschlagenden
aber medikamente und wir haben auch aus
sicht positive aussicht auf impfstoffe
die in den nächsten monaten zugelassen
werden könnte aber es bleibt dabei so
lange das alles nur im ansatz da ist wie
der impfstoff noch in der entwicklung
sicht befindet auch keine
durchschlagende medikamente da sind
müssen wir die nächsten vier monate mit
dieser pandemie leben und alles daran
setzen so viel wie möglich die
verfolgbarkeit die kontrollierbarkeit
hinzubekommen
sonst werden wir eine überlastung
unseres gesundheitssystems sehen was wir
unbedingt vermeiden
danke dafür ich hab als auch eine reihe
von fragen die die kollegen stellen die
uns digital zugeschaltet sind ich werde
versuchen das in einem wechsel zu machen
eine bitte die gilt für den saal genauso
aber auch für die kollegen die ihre
fragen digital stellen bitte fassen sie
sich kurz und beschränken sie sich auf
eine frage sie haben dann die
möglichkeit für eine nachfrage vermeiden
sie vielleicht längere erklärungen damit
wir möglichst viele kollegen dran nehmen
können und zeitlich durchkommen und auch
ein hinweis ein großes dankeschön an die
kollegen dass sie sich an unsere seit
freitag geltende dringende bitte halten
sie an eine maske zu tragen wenn es
ihnen möglich ist gerne auch wenn sie
eine frage stellen und ich beginne mit
einer frage die uns online erreicht hat
von theo geers von deutschlandfunk
er fragt warum haben sie den lockdown
erst ab heute und nicht schon zum
wochenende verhängt da viele gerade
deshalb noch mal schnell restaurants
kneipen schwimmbäder et cetera besucht
haben erschwert das nicht gerade die
eingenommen sicherlich war das eine
abwägung wand zu wand machen wir das auf
der einen seite gibt es solche
erscheinungen das
bestimmte institutionen gleich noch mal
besucht wurden bevor sie bevor sie
schließen auf der anderen seite haben
wir schon in den letzten tagen mit der
höheren diskussion wieder auch
abnehmende mobilität also es ist nicht
so dass alle jetzt noch mal richtig
feiern gegangen sind und zweitens war
die abwägung die dass erstens die länder
ja die entsprechenden verordnungen
machen mussten zum teil in ihren
parlamenten noch debattieren mussten und
die er auch den institutionen eine
gewisse zeit geben wollten zum beispiel
kurzarbeit zu beantragen wenn ich jetzt
mein restaurant schließen muss wenn ich
eine theateraufführung mitmachen muss da
hängen ja sehr viele menschen dran das
waren im grunde die abwägungs gründe
warum wir dann auf diesen montag
gegangen sind dann machen wir weiter in
sein heim in vielen dank philipp menn
ddr frau bundeskanzlerin wir haben heute
mit einem gastronomen aus köln gedreht
was da vor der foto jahres kämpft seit
monaten gegen die auswirkungen dieser
pandemie dass wir ihnen ein
existenzbedrohender kampf den er führt
jetzt muss er einen monat sein
restaurant wieder schließen und seine
große hoffnung ist dass er danach
zumindest das vorweihnachtsgeschäft noch
halbwegs mitnehmen kann
können sie ein foto ihres zusichern dass
er ab anfang dezember wieder sein
restaurant öffnet beziehungsweise wenn
das nicht möglich ist können sie schon
mal den aussicht stellen ob sie diese
hilfen die es jetzt gibt möglicherweise
dann verlängern werden ich möchte heute
über den 30 november noch nicht
spekulieren weil wir dazwischen noch
eine etappe haben und diese etappe heißt
der sechzehnte november nehmen wir uns
mit den ministerpräsidentinnen und
präsidenten wieder treffen werden dann
werden wir analysieren wo stehen wir
ist das ziel für november erreichbar und
müssen der eventuell noch weitere
maßnahmen ergreifen
das heißt wir werden jedenfalls
politisch versuchen alles zu tun damit
es auf den november beschränkt bleibt
ich kann dann nur sagen dass natürlich
ab dezember nicht sozusagen freies leben
wieder stattfindet wie das vor corinna
war sondern die regeln das lüften
all das bleibt gültig das heißt wir
müssen vorsichtig sein damit wir nicht
schnell wieder an dem punkt sind den wir
jetzt leider erreicht haben und der
nicht mehr beherrschbar ist
wenn man nicht etwas tut so deshalb tun
wir alles um das berechenbar zu machen
und wir tun jetzt ja auch sehr viel um
die wirtschaftlichen schäden
auszugleichen und über weiteres möchte
ich jetzt nicht spekulieren
da nehme ich mal die frage von julia
emmrich funkel mediengruppe dazu die
fragt nämlich nach diesem treffen neben
erneuten treffen mit den
ministerpräsidenten in zwei wochen
und fragt nach welchen kriterien dann
entschieden werden soll welche
epidemiologischen kennzahlen sind
entscheidend entscheidend ist die sieben
tage ins tendenz das heißt wir sind
jetzt bei 127,8 wie ich es gesagt haben
mit dem heutigen tag durch
deutschlandweit und wir müssen wieder
runter in den bereich von unter 50 und
weil wir dann sagen können dass die
gesundheitsämter die kontakt
nachverfolgung hinbekommen und wir
werden uns dann anschauen wie sich diese
kurve entwickelt es ist sehr interessant
wenn sie sich mal die israelische kurve
zum beispiel anschauen nach mehreren
wochen wieder an die zahl der
infizierten nach einem sehr viel
härteren lockdown runtergegangen ist das
heißt also es ist unzweifelhaft dass
kontakt beschränkende maßnahmen auch zu
ergebnissen führen
und wir müssen das jetzt eben jeden tag
beobachten aber das ziel ist wieder in
den bereich der kompakten nachverfolgung
für die gesundheitsämter zu kommen wir
werden jetzt auch schauen inwieweit wir
auch den gesundheitsämtern noch
verstärkungen geben müssen in diesen
vier wochen gucken dass das nachhaltig
ist aber sehr viel mehr als 50
infizierte pro 100000 einwohner können
gesundheitsämter nicht als kompakt
nachverfolgung schaffen das ist jetzt
unsere erkenntnis dann hat die nächste
frage sitzt mit abstand hinterher ein
mantra vaters ich würde gerne frau
merkel
16 11 uhr feststellen dass diese
fünfziger regel nicht gilt oder nicht
erreichbar ist welche maßnahmen werden
sagen als nächstes greifen das heißt
welche bereiche müssen sich dann schon
mal darauf einstellen jetzt dass es für
sie auch ein bisschen enger wird und
sollte es im dezember
doch lockerer werden können riskieren
sie dann nicht dass sofort die 2 die
nächste weitere bewohner welle sich auf
fraud ende des jahres beispielsweise
also wir hatten ja im frühling ab anfang
april dann mit unseren vorsichtigen
lockerungen doch den effekt dass viele
menschen sehr vorsichtig waren und dass
wir die pandemie sehr gut unter
kontrolle bekommen haben das wird in der
winterlichen bedingungen weil viel mehr
sich im häuslichen umfeld also innen
abspielt natürlich etwas schwieriger
sein
also es wird nicht nur etwas schwieriger
sein es wird schwieriger sein und es
wird bedeuten dass man sicherlich durch
alle wintermonate die privaten kontakte
auch limitieren muss und so gering wie
möglich halten muss und dann müssen wir
lernen zu schauen was können wir uns
zutrauen was können wir an öffnungen
verkraften und dann werden die hygiene
konzepte zum beispiel der restaurants
wieder zu von ganz großer wichtigkeit
sein die hygiene konzepte der kultur
institutionen und sie sehen ja jetzt
auch eine veränderung im verhalten wenn
man durch berlin geht es gibt viel viel
mehr menschen die eine maske tragen das
hat sich viel stärker eigentlich spielt
im sommer gab es eine vielzahl von
nachlässigkeiten
natürlich und das kann man sich im
herbst und winter so nicht leisten das
heißt also wir sind ganz wesentlich
davon abhängig dass die große zahl der
menschen einfach vernünftig ist und mit
macht und damit andere menschen leben
auch rettet und hilft und ich kann ihnen
heute noch nicht sagen was wir am 16 11
wir haben immer noch großzügigere
kontakt beschränkungen also nicht so
strenge kontakt beschränkungen wie wir
sie damals hatten damals durfte man nur
als einzelne haus stand in die
öffentlichkeit plus eine person mit
einer anderen person aus einem anderen
haus stand das waren damals die dinge
heute haben wir zwei ausstände
das ist sozusagen die erste lockerung
stufe die danach den märz beschlossen
gemacht haben die wird heute angewandt
wenn man nicht zufrieden ist dann könnte
man über so etwas nachdenken aber
ansonsten haben wir tag eins der kontakt
beschränkung und ich kann nur beten dass
wir jetzt das was wir machen müssen dass
das auch wirklich alle versuchen und was
wir vorgesehen haben dann wäre schon
recht viel gewonnen
wir werden dann auch wir haben auch
gesagt die öffnung des schulbetriebes
und kita betriebes verknüpfen wir mit
der hoffnung weil der bund dafür nicht
zuständig ist dass auch dort in den
schulen und kitas strengere regeln
eingeführt werden zum beispiel auch
masken tragen im unterricht das also
nicht nur während des aufenthalts im
schul flur oder auf dem hof sondern auch
im unterricht das machen viele
bundesländer dass es sicherlich auch ein
beitrag der jetzt noch mal ganz
wesentlich sein kann
florian gathmann von spiegel der uns
auch online eine frage gestellt hat
fragt befürchten sie dass die bisherige
hohe akzeptanz der corona park politik
von bund und ländern angesichts der
jüngsten beschlüsse schwinden
na ja ich will mal sagen die menschen
sind natürlich etwas enttäuscht das kann
ich ja auch sehr gut verstehen dass das
ganze so lange anhält also wir haben
sozusagen im märz eine ganz hohe
akzeptanz gehabt da hat man gesagt gut
jetzt gehen wir da in diese sehr großen
kontakt beschränkungen und dann haben
wir die sache vielleicht im griff und
wir hatten dann ein doch unterm strich
recht unbeschwerten sommer in dem auch
vieles ausgenutzt wurde an freiheits
möglichkeiten und der herbst ist jetzt
mit großer wucht gekommen und das
verursacht erstmal enttäuschung und die
vier wintermonate die sind lang november
dezember januar februar und selbst im
märz muss man ja noch den halben märz
dazu rechnen bevor es dann mal richtig
frühling wird und dieses licht am ende
eines tunnels ist jetzt noch ziemlich
weit entfernt
und deshalb verstehe ich schon dass das
schwerfällt und dass man sich damit auch
schwer tut aber es ist ja nicht
sozusagen eine ein politischer beschluss
den wir gefasst haben sondern es ist so
etwas wie eine natur ereignis eine
naturkatastrophe mit der wir umgehen
müssen und in der wir den besten für uns
alle vertretbaren weg finden müssen und
wenn jeder sich sagt mein beitrag dazu
dass dieses virus eingedämmt wird das
ist dass ich verzichte auf kontakte dann
weiß man dass man für die gemeinschaft
auch etwas tut und das kann aus meiner
sicht eine hoffnung und auch ein motiv
seien dafür werbe ich jedenfalls und
daneben das wissen das auch fortschritte
gemacht werden bei impfstoffen die nicht
sofort für alle natürlich gehen werden
bei der beiden schutz bestimmter gruppen
bei den testmöglichkeiten und
medikamenten und das ist aber eine sehr
sehr schwere zeit die von uns keiner
voraussehen konnte und die auch sich
kein mensch gewünscht hat also
ich kann unmut und unwillen verstehen
muss trotzdem für die akzeptanz werben
weil wir keine andere wahl haben
wir gehen mit den fragen im saal in die
mitte zu hören blank als mit diesem
virus zu leben das nicht sehen ob
bundeskanzlerin sie haben früher schon
heute auch wieder auf die akzeptanz der
bürger appelliert welche möglichkeiten
bleiben ihnen oder der politik wenn die
bürger viele nicht mitziehen wollen also
welche möglichkeiten haben sie dann noch
außer dem appell vielleicht einer
weiteren fernsehansprache zum beispiel
auch gerade im privaten bereich wenn die
leute weiter feiern
was können sie dann noch tun also wir
haben ja nach wie vor doch eine
erstaunlich hohe akzeptanz und jeder hat
ja in seinem freundes und familienkreis
doch auch menschen die vielleicht zu der
gruppe gehören die gefährdet sind ich
habe mal mir das angeschaut wir haben in
deutschland ungefähr fast 24 millionen
menschen die über 60 jahre alt sind und
wir haben bei den unter 60-jährigen etwa
2,5 millionen schwerstbehindert also
alleine 26 millionen menschen dass es
sind ungefähr 30 prozent der deutschen
bevölkerung da rede ich jetzt noch gar
nicht von vorerkrankungen und anderen
dingen 30 prozent sind schon mal
sozusagen in einer risikogruppe und das
heißt das wenn man freunde und familien
hat eigentlich fast jeder jemanden kennt
den man eigentlich nicht infizieren
möchte weil er oder sie einem lieb ist
und und auch etwas bedeutet und ich
finde auch wenn man sich vor augen führt
der professor hallek aus köln hat jetzt
am wochenende gesagt er sieht auf der
einen seite die situation auf seiner
intensivstation
er sieht die pflegerinnen und pflegern
mit einer unglaublichen motivation und
ärzte dort arbeiten und er sieht auf der
anderen seite auch
leute die das vielleicht alles gar nicht
wahr haben wollen und das wäre
eigentlich auch kein schönes
gesellschaftsbild von unserer
gesellschaft dass der eine sich um den
anderen nicht kümmert und darüber gar
keinen gedanken verschwendet und deshalb
bin ich optimistisch dass eine sehr sehr
große mehrheit das auch versteht deshalb
haben wir als politiker die
verantwortung dafür auch zu werben und
nicht den kopf in den sand zu stecken
und das ist das was unsere aufgabe jetzt
ist und das tue ich und glaube
eigentlich da dass wir doch ein land
sind dass so etwas auch zustande bringt
ich habe schon manchen stellen gilt
ordnungsrecht ich meine wer jetzt mit 30
leuten erwischt wird auf der straße da
gibt's ordnungsstrafen oder wer ohne
maske erwischt wird aber ich will das
nicht alles nur auf straffe aufbauen
sondern ich glaube in einer demokratie
an die kraft der vernunft und der
verantwortung
online gibt es mehrere fragen zum thema
weihnachten nicht nur stellvertretend
die von rasmus buchsteiner von media
pioneer halten sie es noch für möglich
dass familien zu weihnachten quer durch
deutschland reisen dürfen einander
besuchen und miteinander feiern können
und wovon wird diese entscheidung
abhängen
diese entscheidung hängt davon ab was
wir haben nur mal hinbekommen
also wenn man im november eine sehr
vernünftig sind dann werden wir uns mehr
freiheiten zu weihnachten erlauben
können dass es die großen rauschenden
silvesterpartys gibt das glaube ich
nicht aber dass sich kern familien wie
man so schön sagt auch besuchen können
vielleicht mit vorsichtsmaßnahmen
darüber müssen wir noch mal nachdenken
es gibt ja vorschläge von ein paar tagen
vor quarantäne dass man wenn man
aufeinander trifft dann und die
großeltern besucht zum beispiel sicher
ist dass die kinder oder man selber
nicht infiziert ist das müssen wir dann
sehen aber es wird ein weihnachten unter
corona bedingungen seien aber es soll
kein weihnachten in einsamkeit sein
dann machen wir weiter bei helfried auch
in der mitte frau bundeskanzlerin von
den kritikern
ja gesagt dass zwar grundsätzlich das
einsichtig ist die kontakte zu
reduzieren das aber zu wenig
differenziert wird ein beliebtes
beispiel ist der gegensatz zwischen
friseur und fußpflege zum beispiel was
sagen sie diesen leuten zu denen ja auch
zum beispiel werte gehören die sagen wir
haben unsere einrichtungen sind
eigentlich nicht aufgefallen als
einrichtungen in denen besonders viele
menschen sich infizierte ja das stimmt
für die zeit als wir noch die
allergrößte zahl der infektionsursache
gekannt haben als wir sehr geringe
fallzahlen hat wussten wir auch und
wussten die menschen selber auch wo sie
sich infiziert haben
wenn jetzt von vier menschen drei nicht
wissen wo sie sich infiziert haben
dann weiß ich auch nicht ob sie sich
nicht dort oder dort infiziert haben so
viel feiern und partys und hochzeiten
gibt es gar nicht die im augenblick
menschen infiziert sind
das heißt sie müssen sich irgendwo
infiziert haben und wir wissen nur diese
zahl kriegen wir erst wieder runter und
erst wieder in den bereich wo wir es
nachverfolgen können wenn wir die
kontakte vorher beschränken
und jetzt stehen wir vor der frage
versuchen wir so viel wie möglich sag
ich jetzt mal von dem leben dass
menschen gewohnt sind zu erhalten und da
ist natürlich die frage friseur
fußpflege kosmetik studio tattoo studio
das sind dinge die da können sie sagen
was ist die rationalität wenn sie alle
zu lassen haben sie wieder sechs mal so
viele kontakte oder fünfmal soviel
kontakte wenn sie keinem also man kann
alles zu machen das ist dann sommer
scheinbar das gerechteste aber
vielleicht auch nicht dass
lebenspraktische und wenn wenn sozusagen
die zufriedenheit erst ein kind wenn
möglichst alles zugemacht ist dann ist
das natürlich eine betrachtungsweise die
sowohl wirtschaftlich nicht vernünftig
ist wir haben zum beispiel
ein beispiel zu nehmen ja damals die
baumärkte aufreger aufgehalten im märz
haben aber die autohäuser geschlossen da
konnte man auch fragen warum darf sie im
baumarkt angesagt damit die leute die so
viel zu hause sind irgendwie auch sich
noch betätigen können aber natürlich
hätte man auch das autohaus offen lassen
können wir haben damals nicht überblickt
das mit dem schließen eines autohauses
im grunde der gesamte absatz der autos
weg war weil man online auto kauft ist
noch nicht so populär wie andere dinge
das heißt also der absatz ist vollkommen
zusammengebrochen mit der folge dass
auch die autoproduktion dann noch durch
die schließung von grenzen oder die
kontrollen die durchbrechung der
lieferketten und weil andere in europa
ihren ihre wirtschaftliche tätigkeit gar
nicht fortgesetzt haben haben wir
riesige wirtschaftliche auswirkungen
gehabt und jetzt müssen wir uns fragen
was ist lebenspraktisch etwas was
vernünftig ist worauf kann man
verzichten
aber das ist mit der letzten frage der
gerechtigkeit dann auch nicht zu
erklären sondern nur mit der mit der
bitte für die gemeinschaft ein
erschwernis hinzunehmen und jetzt eben
einen monat nicht den salon auf machen
zu können und deshalb auch die sehr
großzügigen entschädigung weil wir
sozusagen einigen sehr viel zumuten und
anderen das weiterarbeiten ermöglichen
daran anknüpfend nämlich eine frage dazu
von gerd joachim von hannover von
phoenix er fragt wieder zehn milliarden
für die kommenden vier wochen wie lange
können wir uns teil noch tanz oder gar
totalen doctors noch wirtschaftlich
leisten
ja es gibt einen ganz engen zusammenhang
zwischen einem guten bewältigen der
pandemie im blick auch auf
intensivbetten auf menschen die sterben
oder schwere verläufe haben und
wirtschaftlicher wirtschaftlicher
prosperität oder wirtschaftlichen tätig
sein es zu sehen kein gegensatz
ein gutes durchkommen durch die pandemie
ist das beste für die wirtschaft und
jetzt sind wir sozusagen aus unserem
rhythmus gekommen es gab zu viele
kontakte
ein exponentielles wachstum eingetreten
die öffentlichen bedingungen die
klimabedingungen und die räumlichkeiten
haben sich auch verändert jetzt müssen
wir diese balance wiederfinden und muten
einigen sehr viel zu und
glücklicherweise sind wir finanziell als
bundesrepublik deutschland noch in der
lage dieses auch in gewisser weise zu
kompensieren
ich glaube nur wir alle sparen viel geld
wenn wir vernünftig sind das muss man
auch sagen es ist nicht nur das wir
menschenleben retten sondern es ist auch
dass wir dann wirtschaftlich sehr viel
besser durch die sache kommen und das
bedeutet aber eben in einigen bereichen
großveranstaltungen partys feiern wird
es auch nach dem november keine
möglichkeit geben das in üppigen spiel
zu machen das ist absehbar für die vier
wintermonate dann machen wir im saal
weiter und jeden auf die von uns aus
gesehen linke seite zu frau wolff ja
frau bundeskanzlerin ich würde ganz
gerne auch der aspekt der freiheit
eingehen der unter anderem auch im
anschluss an ihre regierungserklärung im
bundestag diskutiert wurde
das bedeutet auch dass meine freiheit
dort endet wo die des anderen beginnt
haben sie das gefühl dass diese einzige
bei dem großteil der menschen präsent
ist oder dass die freiheit oft auch
falsch verstanden wird und daran
anschließend fabrik hat im bundestag
auch die hoffnung geäußert dass
freiheitliche systeme und gesellschaften
sich b-wm in der pandemie bewältigung
wohingegen in autoritären system man die
durchsetzung von regeln sehr viel
leichter ist wie optimistisch sind sie
dass freiheitliche systeme sich dann in
dieser situation auch bewähren können
ich bin da optimistisch aber es
erfordert eine andere art auch der
argumentation und des überzeugen
das muss man mehr tun und es erfordert
eben auch eine seite der freiheit zu
betrachten die vielleicht nicht immer im
vordergrund steht freiheit ist erst
einmal die möglichkeit entscheidungen zu
treffen unter verschiedenen optionen zu
wählen
aber wie sie es richtig gesagt haben
ist schreitet auch freiheit für alle das
heißt ich habe keine unbegrenzte
freiheit und alle anderen ausser mir
müssen sozusagen mit den folgen meiner
freiheit leben das heißt freiheit
unserer freiheitsbegriff ist darauf
angelegt dass es die freiheit ist
verantwortung zu übernehmen
verantwortung für meine familie für
meine mitmenschen für meine gesellschaft
für die nächste generation das machen
wir beim klimaschutz das machen wir bei
anderen fragen dass wir auch darauf
setzen dass wir uns heute nicht
unendlich verschulden damit morgen nicht
die generationen gar keinen spielraum
wir haben also freiheit geht auch mit
der verantwortung innerhalb der freiheit
weit über mein eigenes leben hinaus und
gesellschaften die das leben können
werden sehr gut durch solche
herausforderungen aber auch andere
zeiten kommen und gesellschaften die das
nicht können werden große
schwierigkeiten haben ich wünsche mir
als sozusagen ja auch jemand der durch
die deutsche einheit in die freiheit
gekommen ist dass uns das gelingt aber
es ist eine sehr sehr große
bewährungsprobe wie wir sie im grunde
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg in der form
nicht hatten müssen wir uns immer wieder
vor augen führen das ist nicht irgendwie
ein kleiner eigenes der letzten drei
jahre sondern das ist etwas was uns seit
gründung der bundesrepublik deutschland
gar nicht am meisten ab thailand und uns
ja auch in einer phase trifft in der wir
jetzt etliche jahre wohlstandszuwachs
wirtschaftswachstum senken der
arbeitslosigkeit erlebt haben und all
das gerät jetzt unter druck und das
müssen wir uns wieder arbeiten
ich bleibe mit der nächsten frage im
saal verein weiter vorn welchem
eurodance frau bundeskanzlerin
meine frage schließt sich da ganz gut an
und zwar deutschland ist nicht das
einzige land das sich jetzt mitten in
der pandemie befindet sie haben mehrfach
die bedeutung der internationalen
kooperation bei der bekämpfung der
pandemie unterstrichen
wir wissen aber dass sie keine
wahlempfehlung für amerikaner abzugeben
haben aber ich würde gerne von ihnen
wissen für wie wichtig sie halten das im
weißen haus
die stimme der wissenschaft gehört wird
also ich werde das einen tag vor der
wahl in den vereinigen staaten von
amerika mit sicherheit nicht tun
ansonsten wissen sie von mir als allein
schule bei meiner vorbildung als
physikerin dass ich natürlich den
wissenschaftlichen rat für kraft zu
messe und ihnen auch selber benutze dann
kommen wir weiter zurück die fragen im
saal vielleicht auch weiter eher zu
corona jessen frau bundeskanzlerin sie
haben wiederholt betont es funktioniert
nur wenn freiwillig mitgemacht wird
freiwillig mitmachen beruht aber auf
akzeptanz riskieren sie nicht wenn sie
einrichtungen die eigentlich gastronomie
oder auch kultursektor distanz
möglichkeiten schon geschaffen haben sie
denn noch schließen sie sagte es geht um
das ganze aber diese sektoren könnten
distanz einhalten
riskieren sie damit nicht dass akzeptanz
schwindet und dann eben doch solche
sachen sich ins private verlagert
befördern sie mich das was sie
eigentlich verhindern wollen schauen sie
wir machen doch dass ich gerne sondern
wir haben eine gesellschaft die hat eine
bestimmte zahl von kontakten und die
sind im augenblick zu viel und jetzt
könnten wir sagen wir legen sozusagen
das wirtschaftliche die wirtschaftliche
tätigkeit unterbrechen wir keiner muss
mehr zur arbeit und damit wird jetzt
nichts produziert oder ähnliches und
dafür lassen wir die restaurants auf das
wäre von der kontakt zahl vielleicht
etwas ähnliches aber das würde uns
vielleicht in die lage versetzen dass
wir mit sicherheit nie wieder
die die jetzt schließen entschädigen
könnten weil woanders nichts verdient
wird das heißt wir haben uns sehr gut
überlegt wo reduzieren der kontakt aber
auch das habe ich ja versucht zu sagen
auch in einem
konzertsaal auch in einem restaurant wo
die tische auf 15 meter abstand stehen
oder die menschen auf 15 meter abstand
sitzen müssen die menschen in das
konzert fahren sie werden sich dort
nicht nur auf dem platz aufhalten
sondern vorher auch begegnen aneinander
vorbeilaufen und ähnliches nicht jeder
hat die medizinische ausrüstung einer
fb2 oder sp3 maske der mund- und
nasenschutz ist eine hilfe und er hilft
uns infektionen zu vermeiden aber er ist
ja keine sicherheit dass ich nicht
infiziert werde ich habe also bei der
anfahrt bei der abfahrt beim sprechen in
vor und nach der veranstaltung oder weil
ich nicht kontrollieren kann ob 234
haushalte an einem tisch sitzen wo er
natürlich nicht die ganze zeit überprüft
werden kann wie viele menschen kommen da
zusammen gefahren dann alle wieder nach
hause und gehen in ihre familien hinein
all das müssen wir jetzt unterbinden
weil wir zu hoch sind bei den
infektionen bin für wieder niedrig
können wir uns davon wieder mehr alle
rum und in der abwägung schule oder kita
oder kontakt im konzert oder in der
gaststätte haben wir uns dafür
entschieden wirtschaftskreislauf so weit
wie möglich restaurants sind ja auch
teil des wirtschaftskreislaufs
wirtschaftskreislaufs weit wie möglich
und kitas und schulen und natürlich
krankenhäuser pflegeeinrichtungen und
die infrastruktur so diese entscheidung
ist eine politische wenn ich mir sonst
auf malle wo sind überall kontaktpunkte
in der gesellschaft kann ich auch andere
bereiche raus aus greifen aber ob wir
dann wirtschaftlich so durchkommen dass
wir allen auch noch helfen können und ob
das die richtigen gesellschaftlichen
prioritäten sind das muss man
diskutieren nur wer sagt jetzt habt ihr
an der falschen stelle geschlossen
der muss mir genau sagen an welcher
stelle wir es dann sonst machen soll
und jetzt sind wir es den privaten
bereich genommen indem wo es an die
verantwortung die dem essen sind in
deutschland
nehmen wir machen wir nicht so auch
radikale maßnahmen die sie in unseren
nachbarländern von page im augenblick
wieder in kraft sind
und das bedeutet aber wir müssen ein
stück an die vernunft und an das
verständnis appellieren derer die jetzt
unter arbeits einschränkungen leben
müssen oder gar nicht arbeiten können
und die entschädigung bekommen und dann
auch in der hoffnung dass viele mit uns
teilen dass das aufrechterhalten von
schulen und kitas und des
wirtschaftskreislaufs jetzt das
wichtigste ist und der verwandtenbesuch
die urlaubsreise der restaurantbesuch
die feier im kleinen kreis zu hause und
das auftreten den großen gruppen draußen
vielleicht wenn ich die reduzieren muss
das verträglichere ist aber schwer
bleibt kein mensch hat sich sowas
gewünscht nur wir können ja nicht
zusehen wie wir dann sozusagen menschen
lieben wie wir die überlastung unseres
gesundheitssystems machen denn diese
situation möchte ich nicht kommen das
möchte ich auch pflegerinnen und
pflegern und ärzten und betroffenen
nicht zu es gibt auch fragen nach den
abwägungen von den kollegen online ich
nehme die frage von malte kreutzfeldt er
fragt warum dürfen dann gottesdienste
bei den gruppen in geschlossenen räumen
sitzen und singen weiterhin stattfinden
und nehme einfach meine frage noch mit
dazu von mey dudin pd halten sie die
überlegungen der kirchen für große open
air gottesdiensten zu weihnachten für
verantwortungsvoll
das kommt darauf an wie groß die open
air gottesdiensten sind alles was im
freien passiert ist unter den gleichen
bedingungen also beim gleichen
abstandsregelung immer besser als im
inneren eines raumes wenn die kitas und
schulen offen lassen dann ist die
ausübung der religionsfreiheit nach
einschätzung aller verfassungsjuristen
auch zwingend geboten man kann nicht
kitas und schulen offen halten denn wenn
sie geschlossen hätten hätte man wie im
märz auch überlegen können kann man auch
gottesdienste wieder unterbinden aber in
diesem zusammenhang ist sozusagen das
recht auf religionsausübung ein sehr
hoch stehendes rechte in unserem land
und angesichts der tatsache dass wir
auch andere bereiche wie eben zum
beispiel kitas und schulen offen
gehalten haben und läden
einkaufsläden glauben wir dass wir das
auch tun
dann machen wir im saal weiter bei hair
days und das kann dann muss noch einmal
zu entfernt zurückkommen und so ihr aber
auch sie arbeite ich einen serien wie
grad das signal gegeben dass ich habe
sie so verstanden dass es zu diesem
thema ist aber der liste sind sie
nämlich weiter hinten dann ist nämlich
zuerst heringe dran sorry jetzt könnte
aus solidarität der ringe die frage von
selbst stellen dann wäre auch also nicht
kenne frau bundeskanzlerin ich
tatsächlich noch mal zu einem punkt
zurück und zwar zu den gerichten weil
sie haben jetzt erklärt warum sie diese
andere philosophie haben die kontakte zu
beschränken aber wir haben in den
letzten monaten erlebt dass gerichte
immer wieder politische entscheidungen
der länder gekippt habe was macht sie
eigentlich diesmal so zuversichtlich
dass das diesmal nicht passiert und ihr
konzept gar nicht so sehr von den
einzelnen menschen nicht befolgt wird
sondern von den gerichten zertrümmert
wird
na ja wir haben also erstens dass wir in
einer situation sind wie wir sie seit
märz nicht hatten nämlich in einer
situation wo die überlassung unseres
gesundheitssystems nicht irgendetwas in
weiter ferne liegende ist sondern wo wir
sehr klar nachweisen können dass bei
einer verdopplung von zehn tagen wir in
zwanzig oder spätestens 30 tagen an
einem punkt sind der die überlastung mit
sich bringt das kann man sozusagen sehen
angesichts des infektionsgeschehen und
das können wir nicht zulassen
zweitens indem wir jetzt bundes
flächendeckend im grunde landkreise
haben die alle über 50 liegen dass auf
eine oder zwei bei der instanz das heißt
wir haben einen
ein flächendeckendes ausbleibt sich
ausbreiten des geschehens das spricht
dafür dass man jetzt nicht beliebig viel
mobilität zu lassen kann dann würden
auch noch die anderen etwas weniger
betroffenen regionen natürlich über kurz
oder lang mit einbezogen also wir haben
ein bundesweites handlungsmuster und
indem wir begründen warum wir bestimmte
bereiche herausgenommen haben kita
schule wirtschaftskreislauf andere
bereiche geschlossen haben das ist eine
argumentation der vielleicht gerichte
auch folgen können
schwierig war es immer da wo man sagen
wir mal die eine versammlung erlaubt hat
die andere versammlung nicht erlaubt hat
da ist immer nach dem
gleichheitsgrundsatz gehandelt worden
vielleicht ist manchmal auch nicht
deutlich genug geworden was uns leitet
es geht ja eben nicht um das hygiene
konzept des opern salzer und der des
restaurants b sondern es geht um die
zahl der kontakte und ob das ein
opernhaus kontaktes oder ein arbeitswelt
kontakt oder einen kontakt in einem
freizeitpark das ist für das virus
vollkommen egal
und deshalb müssen wir dann priorisieren
und diese argumentation haben wir
versucht jetzt sehr stringent
durchzugehen und ich kann mir nicht tun
als zu zeigen dass wir das nicht einfach
mal so aus dem ärmel geschüttelt haben
sondern dass wir uns das sehr sehr gut
überlegt haben also das flächendeckende
die nahende überforderung des des
gesundheitssystems wenn wir haben immer
und immer wieder darauf hingewiesen ich
habe ihnen das im juni gesagt er über 1
ist gefährlich wir lagen jetzt bewerten
von 1,314 das ist nicht nachhaltig wenn
das so weiter geht ist vollkommen klar
wo das endet das kann jeder ausrechnen
der sich mit exponential funktionen
auskennt und wir sind ja sozusagen der
kontinent der aufklärung neben
mathematische ausbildung nicht den
stellenwert hat und deshalb
ist hier wirklich wenn es um das wohl
des landes geht handeln geboten
da wäre eine konzerne frage stellen
diese verhältnismäßigkeit weil sie jetzt
aber auch schulen abstellen was wofür es
natürlich gute argumente gibt aber
geschäfte sind ja auch noch auf also wie
machen sie die abwägung zwischen
gastronomie zum beispiel und nicht
lebensnotwendigen geschäft ja also wie
gesagt das ist auch eine ermessensfrage
ich weiß nur die an das interessante ist
man sagt warum haben sie jetzt die
restaurants geschlossen natürlich weil
man dort eng an einem tisch sitzt bei
wir letztlich nicht überprüfen können
wie viel haus stände sitzen an einem
tisch und wenn ich in der öffentlichkeit
sage ich darf mich nur mit zwei haus
stellen treffen und ich will jetzt
überprüfen ob jemand an einem
gaststätten tisch mit drei radständen
sitzt das ist ja einer praxis überhaupt
nicht macht bei sich hatte die kontakt
dichte in gaststätten und restaurants
nicht zwischen den tischen aber an einen
tisch schon für erheblich höher
und zweitens kann die antwort nur sein
wenn es heißt ihr habt restaurants
geschlossen und bars und geschäfte nicht
das ist nicht gerecht dass wir da noch
die geschäfte schließen müssen die
antwort kann nicht sein wir machen
beides wieder auf dann laufen wir in den
ruin jetzt wenn man sagt dass es besser
wenn schon jemand leiden muss dann alle
dann ist das auch eine möglichkeit aber
das ist die möglichkeit die uns allen
viel schwerer fällt und die viel teurer
ist und jetzt versuchen wir es mit der
milderen variante und das ist auch ein
thema die verhältnismäßigkeit ist nicht
nur zwei gleiche sondern in der frage 2
sozusagen zu nicht mehr wirtschaftlich
tätig werden zu lassen oder einen den
ein jahr den andern ein dann ist das
mildere mittel den einen jahren den
anderen ein
und insofern
würde ich mich freuen wenn wir es
hinbekommen nicht um den anforderungen
genüge zu tun alles gleich zu behandeln
und damit sozusagen außer der
klassischen infrastruktur ich glaube
dass strom und elektrizität und wärme
und solche dinge müssen ja produziert
werden krankenhäusern ist am leben
erhalten werden lebensmittel müssen
ausgeliefert werden also wir haben ja
einen kernbereich der infrastruktur der
muss immer offen bleiben sonst kommen
wir gar nicht durch und wenn man sagt
alles andere muss dann wenn man einem
die wirtschaftliche tätigkeit muss alles
andere ausschließen dass es eine
möglichkeit die ich nicht bevorzugen
würde
aber es ist nicht die möglichkeit alles
wieder aufzumachen
da der rasen wir in eine situation die
nicht vertretbar ist aus meiner sicht
wir bleiben im saal mit denise wir haben
auch allen eid geleistet auf das
grundgesetz was mit der würde des
menschen beginnt neben herrn rinke hat
es drum münstermann mit der nächsten
frage ja klasse münstermann rheinischen
post
frau bundeskanzlerin am ende wird ja der
kampf gegen das virus auf den
intensivstationen entschieden wenn man
es mal unterbricht sind die überlastet
oder nicht jetzt kommen von dort
vielleicht noch keine
katastrophenmeldung aber doch sehr
alarmierende
berichte es gibt nicht genug pfleger
schutz material weiß man nicht so genau
sollte sich das verschlimmern was tut
die bundesregierung dagegen gibt es
einen notfall krankenhaus werden
bundeswehrkräfte in krankenhäusern
eingesetzt oder wie ist da der fahren
die bundeswehrkräfte die in
krankenhäusern eingesetzt werden können
sind meist schon in den
bundeswehrkrankenhäusern eingesetzt und
dann haben wir also es gibt ja der
serverkapazitäten sie wissen hier in
berlin gibt es ein krankenhaus was
prophylaktisch gebaut ist zum beispiel
und was noch nicht in anspruch genommen
werden musste und da hätten wir
natürlich auch einige möglichkeiten erst
mal sagen
am sichtbarsten wird gleich der kampf um
das virus auf den intensivstationen
entschieden
aber wenn sie sich mal anschauen welche
schweren krankheitsverläufe es gibt die
auch längerfristige schäden mit sich
bringen dann ist mit diesem virus nicht
zu spaßen das schon aus falsche wort
dann kann man mit diesem virus nicht
leichtfertig umgehen
es gibt acht und drei 34-jährige
menschen die sind von einer nacht auf
der anderen finden die sich auf der
intensivstation wieder
es ist auch nicht das problem der
wohlhabenden gruppen wir sind ein land
das normalerweise das das
präventionsgesetz hat also zu versuchen
möglichst viel schaden abzuwenden und
alle unsere gesetze vom umweltschutz bis
zu verkehrs gesetzen sind darauf
ausgerichtet dass man nicht mal
ausprobiert wie lange kann ich das
belasten also wir haben ja 50 kilometer
oder 30 kilometern pro stunde
geschwindigkeitsbeschränkung doch nicht
weil man nicht auch mit 60 durch eine
straße fahren kann sondern wir haben sie
damit möglichst vielen menschen leben
geschont wird
ich gehe doch nicht immer an die
leistungsgrenze und jetzt muss ich doch
auch gucken wie komme ich kann ich
wirtschaftlich überleben wie kann ich
die wirtschaftskreisläufe die
steuereinnahmen sozusagen das wohl des
volkes sie muss natürlich gegen die
kollateralschäden auch angehen natürlich
passiert auch wie schlimm es beim
menschen zu hause sein müssen
deshalb möchte ich auch nicht unbedingt
eine ausgangssperre in deutschland haben
wenn es irgendwie zu vermeiden ist
deshalb appelliere ich angefangen damit
wir das nicht haben was woanders ist
dass es in österreich das in belgien
dass es in frankreich dem wir sind ja
nicht alleine wir diskutieren manchmal
so als hätten wir uns in deutschland
irgendwas ausgedacht was es sonst auf
der welt nirgendwo gibt das ist das ja
nicht
und dann wird gesagt schweden jahr
schweden hat aber auch eine ganz andere
also ist ein land das hat weniger
ballungszentren dass man im ruhrgebiet
oder ähnlichen überhaupt nicht zu
vergleichen wo menschen sehr viel
dichter aufeinander miteinander leben
und insofern sage ich mal ein bisschen
habe ich sind in rage geredet
also insofern ist vorsicht auf allen
ebenen geboten und nicht erst wenn es
nachher um den um die beachtung die
maschine geht sondern möglichst viele
menschen vor diesen virus zu schützen
und das klappt doch auch gut im endet es
gibt jetzt eine akzeptanz für die maske
hätten wir alles vor anderthalb jahren
nicht vorstellen können wenn ich ihnen
gesagt aber sie sitzen jetzt hier alle
mit maske und tragen die auch geduldig
und sind dann bereit diesen beitrag zu
leisten beim einkaufen und so weiter das
klappt doch auch gut und jetzt muss man
uns noch ein bisschen mehr anstrengen
dann kriegen wir das vielleicht auch
wieder hin die nächste frage hier im
saal hat frau um ein jetzt von uns aus
gesehen rechts frau bundeskanzlerin eine
frage hier steht in deutschland die
gesundheit der bevölkerung an erste
stelle in der pandemie bekämpfung in
polen gegen gerade hunderttausende von
frauen auf die straße stellen gesundheit
hinten heran weil sie um ihre
freiheitsrechte kämpfen wollen was ruft
das bei ihnen hört vorhaben sehr viel
verständnis und konnten sich mit trainer
wird darüber sprechen dass die lage sei
eskaliert
jetzt konnte ich noch nicht sprechen
aber auch beim letzten und physischen
europäischen rat nicht dabei selber in
quarantäne war gut das
demonstrationsrecht wird ja auch in
deutschland genutzt und das ist zu
respektieren das ist teil einer
freiheitlichen gesellschaft aber auch da
kann ich nur sagen sollte das immer mit
abstandsgebot und und den hygieneregeln
stattfinden wenn das stattfindet und ja
das ist zu respektieren dass solche
demonstrationen sind bisher bei uns auch
demonstrationen gibt es gibt in berlin
sehr viel mehr demonstrationen als zu
zeiten vor nicht corona ich würde noch
mal bevor wir im saal weitermachen ein
aspekte die kollegen digital aufwerfen
mit einbringen was herr förster von der
deutschen welle fragt zum beispiel
welche schlussfolgerungen ziehen sie aus
der kritik von verfassungsrechtlern und
parlamentariern dass der bundestag zu
wenig eingebunden wird also der
bundestag wird schon
doch gut eingebunden ich glaube ralph
brinkhaus hat das in der plenardebatte
sehr gut gesagt und vielleicht noch
sonst noch mal vergegenwärtigen die
tatsache dass wir jetzt eine
epidemiologische gesamtlage haben die
ist vom deutschen bundestag
verabschiedet worden es gab damals sehr
lange diskussionen darüber wie lange
wollen wir die gelten lassen und es man
hat sich dann entschieden ist für ein
jahr gelten lassen zu wollen weil man
schon ahnte dass der winter auch
schwierig werden kann
zwischenzeitlich im sommer gab es
diskussionen bis hinein nach anfang
oktober wo die leute noch gesagt haben
dass es jetzt vorbei mit der
epidemiologischen lage können darauf hin
dass davon wurden wir leider eines
besseren belehrt und das war eine
entscheidung des deutschen bundestages
und interessant das verschafft dem
bundesgesundheitsminister bestimmte
sonderrechte die rechte allerdings oder
die grundlagen
auf die sich jetzt die allermeisten der
maßnahmen stützen sind im
infektionsschutzgesetz im paragrafen 28
verankert und dann folgend mit den
länder verordnungsermächtigungen im
paragrafen 32 das heißt dort wird
ausdrücklich gesagt dass aus infektion
logischen gründen auch grundrechte
eingeschränkt werden können jetzt haben
wir ich würde wahrscheinlich sagen zum
ersten mal es hat ende der 50er jahre
schon mal eine grippewelle gegeben aber
wir haben wahrscheinlich in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik jetzt am
längsten andauernde einschränkungen in
dieser art und weise
und jetzt muss man immer sehen man muss
immer gucken wo werden die gesetze
vollzogen beschlossen ist dass alles im
deutschen bundestag debattieren diese
woche wieder dass dort der
bevölkerungsschutz gesetzt manche sagen
jetzt müssen wir auch hier nochmal
deutlich darüber gelaufen jetzt ja die
gespräche deutliche veränderung
infektionsschutzgesetz machen
wir müssen jetzt nur aufpassen das
infektionsschutzgesetz ist für alles für
jede art von infektionskrankheit
und wenn wir jetzt ins bild kroner
spezifischen maßnahmen beschäftigen zum
beispiel jeder muss eine maske tragen
dann kann das bei der nächsten infektion
die unser alt genau das falsche mittel
sein und dann müssen wir alle handschuhe
tragen oder wie ihr es wahrscheinlich am
besten handschuhe und masken auch aber
jedenfalls kann eine ganz andere sache
sein und das hat meinem gesetzen
verankern ist auch nicht einfach es gibt
bereiche wenn wir jetzt mal über kita
und schulschließungen reden um kontakte
zu reduzieren mit denen hat der bund
werde nichts zu tun die können nur durch
die länder vollzogen werden weil wir für
die schule keine zuständigkeit haben das
heißt also man kann jetzt diskutieren
können wir da noch mehr spezifik durch
den gesetzgeber verankern
aber die grundentscheidung dass es jetzt
eine besondere zeit ist vom bundestag
getroffen worden und was wir als
regierung jetzt gesagt haben weil es so
eine lange zeit ist und weil zwei andere
verfassungsorgane ja permanent im
gespräch sind nämlich die
bundesregierung und die der bundesrat im
grunde in form der ministerpräsidentin
und bindet ministerpräsidenten dass wir
so ähnlich wie wir
in europa machen nachdem zbg heißt es
gesetzt glaube ich permanente
berichtspflichten einzuführen über das
was wir außerhalb des bundestages tun
dazu bin ich zum beispiel offen also
dass man in einer solchen
epidemiologischen lage sagt ok wann
immer mpk und bundesregierung
zusammentreffen ist die bundesregierung
verpflichtet zu unterricht wann immer
landesgesundheitsminister mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister sprechen
analog zu sein immer staats und
regierungschefs oder gesundheitsminister
auf europäischer ebene sprechen muss der
deutsche bundestag informiert werden und
das könnte ich mir sehr gut vorstellen
weil das eine praxis ist die wirtin
blick auf europa jetzt schon eine ganze
zeit ausüben und die uns letztlich
gestärkt hat in unserer legitimation als
bundesregierung
wir haben noch eine knappe viertelstunde
zeit ich schließe jetzt zumindest schon
mal die frageliste online fragen sind
auch noch reichlich da ich kann nicht
versprechen dass jeder mit seiner frage
rankommt daher nochmal die bitte am
liebsten mit kurze frage kurze antwort
frau dankbar hat die nächste frage bitte
das davor nehmen
frau bundeskanzlerin ich habe eine frage
noch mal zur kultur sie haben vorhin
gesagt dass das eine dass die kultur für
uns alle ein besonderes opfer bringt und
dass das auch eine politische
entscheidung war müsste es jetzt nicht
so auch sein dass es eine politische
entscheidung ist die kultur dann auch
entsprechend zu entschädigen viele von
gerade von den solo selbstständige von
den künstlern sind ja es sind ja im
frühling durchs raster gefallen und die
werden auch keine auftrittsmöglichkeit
haben denn dann der november vorbei ist
ist es da nicht noch ein besonderes
programm geben um die die fast ein
bisschen wie gesagt durchs raster
gefallen sind vielleicht etwas zu
entschädigen also wir müssen glaube ich
der zwei dinge unterscheiden das eine
ist sind die kulturschaffenden und in
die kultur branche inklusive der messe
und veranstaltungs ding sind die
eigentlich gut durch unsere gesamt
hilfen berücksichtigt worden und da gibt
es sicherlich komplikationen stichwort
solo selbstständige haben sie eben
genannt und da haben wir heute im corona
kabinett darüber diskutiert die
überbrückungshilfe bei peter altmaier
diese 25 milliarden zu verlängern und
auch auch solo selbständige sollen da
ein zugang haben
das funktioniert nicht in allen fällen
sommer lebenspraxis gerecht dass der
eine punkt da kümmert sich unsere
staatsministerin monika grütters auch
sehr stark darum der andere punkt ist
was tun wir jetzt für diesen november
und da sind die künstler und
kultureinrichtungen die vereine und alle
die das betrifft miterfasst
im grundsatz damit zu sagen was war im
november letzten jahres und wer das
jetzt nicht kann oder dort gerade eine
besondere lage bei gegebener zeit auch
im jahresdurchschnitt da wollen wir sehr
praktisch sein
das ist aber wie sich schon richtig
sagen nicht die antwort für die ganze
branche die auch vorher sich schon nicht
dazu in allen fällen so gut behandelt
gefühlt wir haben diese speziellen
künstler hilfen von einer milliarde die
frau grütters verwaltet aber da gab es
noch viele fragezeichen für die november
glaube ich kriegen wir das doch
hoffentlich sehr gut hin und auch
praktikabel
man merkt dann immer dass es ganz ganz
viele
individuelle fallgestaltungen gibt und
es ist nicht so ganz einfach also
gerecht zu werden wir müssen ja auch
immer so ein kleines bisschen gucken
einerseits solle unbürokratisch sein
anbau anderer selbst darf sich
missbrauch anfällig sein denn dann muss
missbrauch auftritt dann gibt es ja auch
wieder richtigerweise darüber
berichterstattung also das ist schwierig
und dann will ich auch hin zu sagen es
ist natürlich so wo menschen in
kurzarbeit sind wo menschen unsicherheit
haben wo es jetzt wenn das restaurant
gearbeitet kein trinkgeld gibt und so
weiter also lebenspraktisch und das
einbußen selbst bei guten entscheidungen
das wissen wir und deshalb ist das auch
haut für die betroffenen die nächste
frage jetzt von handys der frau
bundeskanzlerin
wie gesagt ich will jetzt keine
wahlempfehlung von ihnen natürlich aber
doch noch mal die frage wann man sieht
ja aus den usa
dieser tage doch verstörende bilder
eines präsidenten denn dezitiert anderen
ansatz hat seine maske ins publikum
wirft der lockdown weiteren lockt dann
ausgeschlossen hat meine frage ist
erstmal wie erklären sich eigentlich
dass populisten wie trump so einen ganz
anderen ansatz wählen im umgang mit
dieser pandemie
da gibt es noch eine reihe anderer
beispiele das sind auch alles männer so
weit ich das überblicken kann
woran das woran liegt das eigentlich
dass sie das so anders macht man zweite
frage ist was für einen effekt haben
diese bilder eigentlich ihrer meinung
nach auch auf das deutsche publikum weil
ich meinen immerhin ist es der us
präsident das macht in russland ist es
ähnlich szenario eine andere große
demokratie es gibt ja offenbar andere
herangehensweisen wie sehr verzerrt dass
die debatte bei uns meinen sie wir sind
ein freiheitliches land zudem gehört
meinungsfreiheit und auch
natürlich dann die möglichkeit dass
menschen zuweilen wann immer sie
stattfinden entscheiden können und das
ist in den feindlichen staaten von
amerika ganz unterschiedliche meinungen
gibt und dass das land auch alles andere
als einheitlich ist das weiß ja jeder
ich weiß nicht genau was was welchen
einfluss auf wen hat ich weiß nur dass
auch in deutschland wir menschen da sind
die skeptiker sind die verein und als ob
gar von einer sind von jeglicher gefahr
die von dem kroner virus ausgeht und
dass wir uns natürlich auch wege finden
müssen immer wieder zu argumentieren und
da wo argumente dann auch keinen keinen
niederschlag finden einfach damit zu
leben dass nicht alle einer meinung sind
in einer gesellschaft das gehört dazu
und so dankbarer bin ich das doch sehr
viele der meinung sind und sich solchen
meinungen anschließen die nächste frage
hat herr schuler
ich würde doch mal gerne auf die instanz
50 zurückkommen bedeutet das wenn die
institute 50 überschritten wird dass wir
dann einen dauer lockdown gehen und
anstelle einer nachfrage sind sie
erkältet
ich war erkältet sehr erfolgreich
getestet und jetzt bin ich eigentlich
nicht erkältet aber vor einer woche weiß
das stimmt und mich entspannen hat uns
ja ganz normal im groner kabinett gesagt
dass wir jetzt in den winterwochen damit
rechnen müssen dass jedes jede woche
wahrscheinlich zwei bis drei millionen
menschen in deutschland erkältet sind
das wird noch mal eine
riesenherausforderung auch bei dem test
fragen sein wie wir das alles
auseinanderhalten also der einfachen
schnupfen alleine ist noch keine evidenz
für die tatsache dass man sich mit dem
virus infiziert hat wir haben das ziel
in dieser größenordnung von 50
wiederzukommen und auch dann werden ja
weiter kontakt beschränkungen gelten das
hatten wir auch vorher vor also
im oktober und september hat mehr auch
beschränkungen und wir müssen durch die
wintermonate kommen und gucken was wir
uns leisten können und da muss man dann
sehen mit welcher mit welcher art von
veranstaltungen wir rechnen können mit
welcher nicht wir haben gesagt wo es
veranstaltungen wird das bis jahresende
nicht geben also es wird am ersten
dezember nicht die normalität einkehren
wie wir sie von erkannte eine frage
nämlich noch mal von den kollegen
digital der tod der kollege werner
kohler von der saarbrücker zeitung fragt
nochmal nach den wirtschaftlichen
auswirkungen und konkret nach der
mehrwertsteuersenkung muss die
verlängert werden und wann entscheiden
sie darüber wir entscheiden darüber
nicht und sie läuft automatisch aus das
war eine sehr kurze antwort da machen
wir weiter im saal würde eine menge ruft
goodbye kollegen in den verbleibenden
fünf minuten bundeskanzlerin sie haben
ja gesagt das virus bleibt wird uns erst
mal begleiten wir müssen mit dem virus
umgehen und gibt es ja auch durchaus
kritische stimmen die sagen dass es
eigentlich auch einen längerfristigen
umgang mit diesem virus leben kann man
vielleicht nicht die fragen des lockdown
zu perpetuieren kann gibt es eine
längerfristige strategie die vielleicht
auch andere wege im umgang mit dem virus
gefunden werden nehmen wir verändern uns
ja einen umgang eigentlich permanent
also danke für die frage war immer
gesagt wird wir haben keine strategie
zum schutz zum beispiel von
risikogruppen oder wohin haben gruppen
die man sagt das ist ja nicht wahr die
haben jetzt zu möchten mit der neuen
test forderung des
bundesgesundheitsministers der
bundesgesundheitsminister wird ja morgen
auch noch mal hier mit fachleuten rede
und antwort stehen
wir haben eine ganz neue test strategie
wir können jetzt mit schnelltests im
grunde
besucher die in altenheime und
pflegeheime gehen testen
da haben wir jetzt sich dann übernimmt
die krankenkasse die kosten
in einer bestimmten zahl von für eine
bestimmte zahl von besuchen pro monat
das ein riesenfortschritt auch im sinne
des schutzes aber das kostet wieder zeit
und das muss durch medizinisches
fachpersonal durchgeführt werden also
jetzt muss man gucken wo kriegt man die
ganzen leute her dann in dem pflegeheim
ist ja sowieso schon sehr viel zu tun
aber die möglichkeit gibt es die gab es
im märz überhaupt nicht diese
schnelltests manchmal wird gefragt
worden habt ihr euch im sommer nicht
vorbereitet diese schnelltest gibt es
erst seit vielleicht vier bis acht
wochen die produktion im augenblick
kriegen wir zehn millionen im monat kann
sein dass wir im januar 20 millionen
bekommen davon
dann können wir wieder ganz anders
rangehen und können überlegen ob man das
auch bei besuchen von vielleicht
großeltern für menschen die gar nicht im
pflegeheim leben machen
also wir werden den schutz immer weiter
verbessern können aber mit auch den
möglichkeiten die wir haben und insofern
ist die langfriststrategie ist wo immer
wieder medizinisch mein ding durch
testmöglichkeiten oder durch medikamente
die sache besser in den griff bekommen
können wir wieder etwas mehr freiheiten
zu lassen
und ich möchte wirklich diese
vereinsamung nicht mehr dass wir alles
schön weihnachten feiern und ins
restaurant gehen können aber dafür die
menschen in pflegeheimen und die alleine
leben keine besuch anfangen können das
ist für mich keine gute abwägung und wo
immer wir das noch nicht haben müssen
wir uns mehr einschränken aber und die
langfriststrategie heißt einfach solange
wir keine herdenimmunität haben also
solange wir noch anfällig für dieses
virus sind müssen wir mit diesem virus
leben und müssen wir nicht sagen wir
wollen gar keine infizierten mehr das
wird man nicht schaffen aber wir wollen
sie so niedrig halten dass wir das
nachverfolgen können und nicht in dieses
exponentielle wachstum hineingehen und
das wird die jahreszeit mäßig
unterschiedlich sein das wird
immer wieder auch priorität
entscheidungen mit sich bringen und das
wird sehr sehr davon abhängen die die
menschen eben auch die beschränkung
annehmen und verantwortlich für sich
selber handeln und mit dem einführen
eines impfstoffes kommen wir dann
schrittweise natürlich dass wir erst mal
vielleicht wir werden jetzt an dem
nächst ethischen vorschläge bekommen der
ständigen impfkommission der leopoldina
und der ethikkommission
das sind die prioritäten wer muss zuerst
geimpft werden da werden sicherlich
risikogruppen auch dabei sein werden
kritische infrastruktur dabei sein denke
ich mir ich weiß es nicht aber könnte
man sich denken und dann werden wir
wieder gruppen besser schützen können
dann wäre immer noch nicht alle impfen
können auf einmal und dann wird das
schritt für schritt sich verbessern das
ist unsere langfriststrategie als wir
müssen gucken was haben wir für
hilfsmittel in der hand aber die
separation alle risikogruppen aus der
gesellschaft unter dem motto ihr nehmt
jetzt mal am gesellschaftlichen leben
nicht mehr teil und der anderen feiert
party das wäre erstens falsch weil auch
ganz viele junge natürlich weniger aber
es gibt schwere krankheitsverläufe auch
bei jüngeren und andererseits wurde
esswein vorstellungen nicht entsprechen
werden das was man als risikogruppe
bezüglich dieses virus bezeichnet sind
30 bis 40 prozent unserer gesellschaft
und wenn dann gesagt wird naja man kann
den noch mal essen nach hause bringen
für 30 bis 40 prozent unserer
gesellschaft jeden tag als sozusagen den
einkaufsdienst zu erledigen das ist
nicht so ganz einfach herzustellen es
ist handelt sich hier nicht um eine
kleine gruppe von zwei prozent wir sind
auch kein afrikanisches land in dem zwei
drittel der menschen unter 30 jahre alt
sind sondern wir sind eine gesellschaft
die einen großen anteil älterer menschen
hat und deshalb müssen wir als
gesamtgesellschaft darauf die richtigen
antworten finden
schaffen wir noch eine frage auch eine
schaffende diese letzte frage herr
gabriel es auf der fonds gewonnen
das café ist für den deutschlandfunk ich
würde noch mal ganz kurz zum schluss auf
die schuhe
und noch mal blicken da wird ja gerade
diskutiert auch aus den
oppositionsparteien im bundestag kommt
die kritik
man hätte schon wie er handeln müssen
sie haben darauf verwiesen dass es
länder sei aber trotzdem noch mal
jetzt werden belüftungssysteme mobile
thematisiert macht das aus ihrer sicht
sinn oder wie könnte man den
schulbetrieb aber auch den
kindergartenbetrieb so normalisieren und
anschließend daran viele familien
kämpfen auch aktuell mit quarantäne
regelung wenn eine erzieherin zum
beispiel infiziertes und sie haben ja
selbst gesagt der winter wird lang was
sagen sie diesen familien die die
rendite gruppen oder schulklassen
angeschlossen werden und das
wahrscheinlich auch mehrmals in den
nächsten vier monaten ja auf diese
letzte letzte aufgeworfene frage die er
in der tat eine ist haben wir für dieses
jahr ja die antwort gefunden dass eltern
mehr tage bekommen an denen sie
lohnausgleich bekommen wenn das kind
erkrankt ist in diesem fall ist es nie
erkannt sondern durch die quarantäne
das heißt wir haben jetzt nicht nur die
zehn tage pro elternteil glaube ich das
haben wir noch mal um 10 glaube ich
erhöht und jedenfalls deutlich mehr
und das war eine der versuch einer
antwort weil wir das natürlich nicht
ausschließen können dass auch als hier
betroffen sind von quarantäne regelung
und das zweite ist was den schulbetrieb
anbelangt wir haben gesagt wir
unterstützen über den digital packt
hinaus noch mal jetzt mit 500 millionen
euro die anschaffung von computern von
tablets für kinder die sich selber
keines leisten können für 500 millionen
euro die ausstattung der lehrerinnen und
lehrer mit tablets die weiterbildung der
lehrer um auch digitale möglichkeiten
besser zu unterstützen wir haben eine
milliarde in die hand genommen um
lüftungssysteme jetzt nicht direkt in
schulen es sei dann in einer aula oder
aber in bürgerhäusern zu verbessern
damit
dort die luftqualität besser ist und
dass es nicht wieder das passiert was in
gangelt passiert ist wo eben nicht die
modernste lüftungsanlage eingebaut war
wir haben über das über das
gemeindeverkehrsfinanzierungsgesetz
glaube ich den ländern geld gegeben
extrageld damit mehr schulbusse
eingesetzt werden können damit dass
dieser schulbus verkehr entzerrt werden
kann
also wir helfen an vielen stellen und
ich glaube dass es aber auch eine
gemeinschaftliche aufgabe von bund
ländern und kommunen ist dass jeder auf
seinen teil dazu beiträgt hamburg zum
beispiel gibt jetzt jedem glas jeder
klasse was ich toll finde 400 euro in
hamburg und die können sich dann
entsprechende anlagen co2 messgerät
filteranlagen oder ähnliches kaufen bei
diesem filteranlagen ist es so dass wir
noch vor zwei drei monaten gesprochen
haben da war noch nicht ganz klar was
diese anlagen auch wirklich bringen wir
müssen ja auch gegenstände machen die
die etwas bringen ich kann jetzt nicht
jedes klassenzimmer mit dem ehepaar
schild ausstatten das wäre glaube ich
nicht möglich und insofern wenn es
technische entwicklungen gibt dann wird
es auch wege geben und da glaube ich
will ich gar nichts ab wenn ich will nur
sagen wir haben an einigen stellen schon
einiges gemacht und verschließen uns
auch nicht anderen dingen aber länder
und kommunen sind sicherlich auch
leisten auch ihre beiträge um
verbesserungen durchzuführen dann danke
ich für das verständnis dass nicht jeder
mit seiner frage dran gekommen ist auch
wir wollen nach einer gewissen zeit hier
aber auch wieder frische luft rein
kommen lassen und wir danken vor allen
dingen frau merkel kommen
dankeschön
soweit also die pressekonferenz mit der
bundeskanzlerin wir wollen gleich noch
mal sprechen auch darüber mit unserem
korrespondenten in der hauptstadt mit
florian neuhann vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz vorher zusammengefasst die
wesentlichen aussagen der kanzlerin zu
den ja teilweise muss man ja sagen
locker und maßnahmen jetzt eben verhängt
worden sind also sie hat gleich davon
gesprochen dass es sich eben dabei um
ein jahrhundert-ereignis halten handeln
würde und deswegen eben auch da nicht
mit kleineren maßnahmen zurechtgekommen
werden kann sondern dass es wegen
wirklich schwierige entscheidungen sind
dass sie sich sehr darüber bewusst ist
auch mitsamt der kompletten
bundesregierung dass das ein großer
verzicht ist der der bevölkerung der
abverlangt wird dieser sei aber
notwendig verdreifachung der zahlen in
14 tagen wir hätten ein exponentielles
wachstum und die kontakt verfolgung sei
eben zu großen teilen zu 75 prozent
sagte die kanzlerin nicht mehr möglich
die bundes die gesundheitsämter parteien
müssten wieder in die lage versetzt
werden dass das möglich ist und dafür
sei eben die sieben tages inzidenz
entscheiden die müsse wieder unter den
wert von 50 pro 100.000 einwohner sinken
inzwischen ist aber bei 120 oder 130 so
zehn milliarden euro das vielleicht auch
noch ein wichtiger punkt steht für die
wirtschaft bereit also es wird geholfen
finanziell aber natürlich sind mit
diesem lockt viele einschränkungen
verbunden und viele branchen leiden
darunter
ganz besonders es wird mit sicherheit
auch kritik geben wir nehmen diese
pressekonferenz jetzt nochmal wie gesagt
zum anlass darüber zu sprechen auch mit
unserem korrespondenten mit florian
neumann der uns zugeschaltet ist aus
berlin
florian vielleicht gleich noch mal die
frage an die ich die kanzlerin hat
deutlich gemacht dass sie eine
pressekonferenz selber macht und zwar
auch mit dem grund das ist eben diese
bedeutung hat wie überzeugend hat die
kanzlerin aus deiner sicht die gründe
für diese maßnahmen jetzt darlegen
können
na ja die ist naturwissenschaftlerin
hatten immer wieder auch betont wie
wichtig es ist diese exponential
funktionen des virus das exponentielle
wachstum einzugrenzen und das hat mich
natürlich schon sehr überzeugend
dargelegt
die frage ist ob am ende die bürgerinnen
und bürger ihr folgen werden denn davon
hängt der erfolg dieser maßnahmen ab das
hat sie auch mehrfach gesagt denn ohne
eine mitwirkung der
gesamten bevölkerung eines großteils der
bevölkerung wird es eben nicht gelingen
diese hohe intelligenz du hast gerade
erwähnt von 127 auf unter 50 zu drücken
das ist ja ein erheblicher weg den man
dann auch gehen muss und insofern diese
appell an die vernunft und gleichzeitig
für mich eine wichtige erkenntnis das
ende der maßnahmen ist eben nicht
festgelegt sondern wer hat gesagt ist
gesagt die wir jetzt nicht über den
dreißigsten november also das ende
spekulieren
das heißt möglicherweise werden die
maßnahmen verlängern vielleicht auch
verschärft deswegen anders eben davon ab
wie sich die korona intelligenz zahlen
in den nächsten tagen und wochen
entwickeln
wir wollen unsere user mit einbeziehen
an unsere in unserer gespräch zb jonas
wagner über youtube der fragt oder sagt
ich frage mich warum man sich nicht im
sommer gedanken darüber gemacht hat und
frühzeitig maßnahmen beschlossen hat
also ähnliche maßnahmen wie sie jetzt in
beschlossen worden sind ähnlich auch
andrea dort über facebook warum wurden
die sechs monate nicht genutzt und die
gesundheitsämter besser aufzustellen
also im prinzip sind das alles fragen
die sich darum drehen kommt der
zeitpunkt jetzt zu spät hätte man das
alles vorher wissen müssen wie ist das
einzuschätzen aus politischer sicht nein
der vaart ich finde diesen fragen völlig
berechtigt was hat die bundesregierung
getan in den letzten wochen um sich auf
diese zweite welle vorzubereiten sie
kommt ja nicht überraschend dass im
herbst und winter die menschen eher im
drinnen sich aufhalten und deswegen auch
die infect das infektionsrisiko steigt
konnte niemanden überraschen wenn man
dann ins detail schaut ist die sache
nicht ganz so einfach denn zum beispiel
gesundheitsämter aufzustocken person der
ich das lied nicht mal eben so oder auch
die intensivpatienten zb intensivpfleger
jetzt zu finden das schafft man nicht
von heute auf morgen
man hat ja die bundeswehr verpflichtet
soldaten die jetzt in gesundheitsämtern
aushelfen trotzdem kann man in vielen
bereichen fragen zu stellen ob man nicht
hätte sich besser vorbereiten müssen
also zum beispiel die lüftungsanlagen
die jetzt nach und nach irgendwann den
schulen schulklassen trainiert werden
müssen
warum hat man nicht im sommer da die
vorkehrungen getroffen diese frage muss
man in der tat der bundesregierung
wieder und wieder stellen
vielen dank für diese einschätzung
florian wir bleiben dran die
bildqualität ist leider nicht besonders
berauschend wir bitten das zu
entschuldigen wir hören die ich
allerdings gut ich mach mal weiter mit
anton der über facebook schreibt waren
acht monate eigentlich zu kurz um das
gewählte parlament in die
maßnahmenplanung einzubeziehen also
hintergrund dieser frage ja auch die oft
geäußerte kritik dass momentan viel eben
an den volksvertretern vorbeiläuft dazu
hat sich die kanzlerin ja auch geäußert
ja genau das eben auch eine frage
denn in der tat sind die maßnahme
beschlossen worden und am tag danach
erst vom parlament nur noch quasi pro
forma diskutiert worden jetzt hat merkel
angekündigt hatte sich vorstellen kann
dass wie bei jeder unterricht bei jeder
bei jedem treffen mit dem
ministerpräsidenten das parlament
unterrichtet werden muss das dürfte aber
die opposition und die kritik aus dem
bundestag nicht zufrieden stellen denn
die wollen ja entscheidend bevor eben
merkel und die mps eine neue maßnahme
treffen
fragen wir vielleicht gerade noch mal
nach der nachhaltigkeit der maßnahmen
dort ist gerade auch schon angesprochen
aber das war ja eben auch ein wichtiger
punkt darüber hatten wir auch schon vor
der pressekonferenz miteinander
gesprochen was bedeutet dieses
maßnahmenpaket sozusagen für den
zeitraum danach also jetzt ist der
november sozusagen in trockenen tüchern
aber was heißt das dann für den zeitraum
ab dezember vor weihnachten worauf
müssen sich die leute da einstellen hat
die kanzlerin darauf auch schon eine
zufriedenstellende antwort geben können
zufrieden stellt nun doch nicht das muss
jeder für sich selber bewerten
der entscheidende satz von merkel war da
das am ersten dezember man nicht eben
zur normalen bisherigen vor corinna
gewöhnen sozusagen blockieren kann das
leben wird mich wieder so sein wie
vorher wir werden uns weiterhin
anstrengen müssen in sachen kontakten in
sachen lüften auch in sachen machten
tragen und wie ich gerade eben sagte das
ende dieser maßnahmen ist offen das habt
ihr gerade eben deutlich gesagt also ob
die maßnahme die beschränkungen nach
diesen vier wochen zurückgezogen werden
das konnte sie jetzt nicht zu sichern
es wird am 16 november eine
zwischenbilanz gezogen von martina dem
ministerpräsidenten und dann wird man
entscheiden oder zumindest wird man sich
anschauen ob diese maßnahmen gewirkt
haben und eine entscheidung die wird
dann wahrscheinlich erst kurz vor dem 30
11 getroffen
magic it fragt über youtube wie ist es
zu erklären dass kultur einrichtungen
wie theater schließen müssen wobei
gottesdienste weiter veranstaltet werden
dürfen ich erinnere mich das war auch
eine frage in der pressekonferenz des
hängt so weit ich das jetzt erinnere
auch mit den schulen zusammen das
korrespondiert miteinander wenn schulen
und kitas offen bleiben dann muss im
prinzip auch die religionsfreiheit
gewährleistet sein
genau es geht jetzt nicht mehr um die
vergleichbarkeit der maßnahmen die
natürlich ein großes großes problem ist
bei einer so weitreichenden
einschränkungen des öffentlichen lebens
merkel hat das ziel immer wieder
formuliert drei von vier kontakten
müssen reduziert werden sollen also weg
seien 75 prozent weniger kontakte unter
der prämisse dass eben schulen kitas
offen bleiben muss man anderswo
einschränken das betrifft eben dann
kultur und gastronomie
was die kirchen betrifft so ist eben die
religionsfreiheit im grundgesetz
verankert und da in dieser region
verhängt einzuschränken
das könnte eben an gerichten scheitern
deshalb hat man darauf verzichtet noch
eine frage über facebook chris la luna
die grenzen bleiben offen oder werden
die geschlossen ist es in der tat ein
szenario mit dem sich beschäftigt wird
auch grenzen wieder dicht zu machen ja
dass man sich damit beschäftigen findet
auszugeben aber ich denke das wird als
allerletzte maßnahme erfolgen denn man
hat gesehen im frühjahr dass diese
maßnahme nicht gut ankamen wieder bei
der bevölkerung noch bei den
europäischen nachbarn also vorerst
bleiben die grenzen offen aber dass man
sich damit beschäftigt für den notfall
auch grenzen zu schließen davon muss man
ausgehen
elke ständer fragt über youtube was ist
mit den kindern in der schule auch eben
viele fragen über youtube dass die
schulen eigentlich auch geschlossen
werden sollten auch das natürlich ein
wichtiger punkt warum passiert das
momentan nicht dazu hat sich die
kanzlerin auch geäußert die schule hat
einen besonderen stellenwert im moment
kitas ja man hat wenn ich aus dem früher
gelernt dass im frühjahr wurden ja die
schulen über lange wochen geschlossen
und es gab das homeschooling was für
viele eltern eine große belastung war
und was auch zu einer großen
ungerechtigkeit geführt hat denn nicht
überall konnten neben die kinder so
betreut werden wie es vielleicht
erforderlich gewesen wäre
deswegen gilt jetzt eben als oberste
regel dass man versucht schulen kitas so
lange aufzuhalten wie irgend möglich das
hat merkt es auch wieder erneut betont
denkbar sind allerdings weitere
einschränkungen zum beispiel das also
masken im unterricht dauerhaft getragen
werden müssen oder auch dass man
irgendwann über über einen wechsel
unterricht nachdenken also klassen zum
beispiel teilt aber man will eben das
hat aber auch die mps gesagt letzte
woche die schulen so lange aufhalten wie
es nur geht
eine wichtige entwicklung auch in der
pandemie home office arbeit zuhause
dieser teller fragt mich würde
interessieren warum die leute nicht mehr
angeregt werden ins home office zu gehen
naja ich finde wir werden schon sehr
stark angeregt das gab vergangene woche
auch die äußerungen vom arbeitsminister
hubertus heil der gesagt hat wo immer es
möglich ist bittet er alle menschen auf
dem home office zu arbeiten
also ich wusste nicht wie es noch mehr
gehen sollte es ist einfach so dass
nicht bei allen menschen das möglich ist
dass ich aus dem home office
herausarbeiten man denke eben keine
ahnung an taxifahrer ein busfahrer
andacht und pfleger nächsten müssen eben
ab und zu ins studio gehen und wenn wir
fragen stellen an die kanzlerin dann
sind wir eben auch meistens vor ort aber
überall dort wo es möglich ist gibt es
diese aufforderung seit tagen und wie
ich das erlebe zumindest hier im
privaten umfeld wird das auch im volk
reden wir noch ganz kurz über die
familien da fragt marina glorius gibt es
hilfen für familien die durch kurzarbeit
verminderte einnahmen haben also wird da
noch mal ein besonderer schwerpunkt
seitens der regierung draufgelegt
naja kurzarbeit ist ja bereits eine form
der hilfe da gibt es ja einen ganz
großen eine ganz große förderung durch
den staat insofern keine explizite
förderung von familien ist hat ja die
entscheidung gegeben von 300 euro als
kinderbonus in dieser krise der nach und
nach
gezeigt wird das war die grosse
familienförderung die ist in dieser
krise gegeben hat eine weitere förderung
ist derzeit zumindest meines wissens
nicht vorgesehen
gut dann vielleicht noch mal
abschließend an dich noch mal die frage
zu deiner einschätzung also das kommt
jetzt von mir die kanzlerin hat gesagt
worauf es ankommt wird in den nächsten
wochen die kontakte zu reduzieren was
glaubst du was wird entscheidend sein
dafür dass die leute mitmachen
entscheidend ist aber ich schon dass man
ihnen eine perspektive gibt für die zeit
danach also eine ungewissheit ob diese
maßnahmen jemals enden das wird
irgendwann zu einer ganz großen chor
ohne müdigkeit führen glaube ich es
braucht diese perspektive für eine zeit
nach diesem lockdown diese perspektive
gibt es aber aktuell nicht und das ist
die große schwierigkeit mit der merkel
jetzt in die nächste zeit geht also die
appelle die haben wir gehört und sie
werden sicherlich auch für eine gewisse
zeit fruchten aber die müdigkeit der
bevölkerung wird nach und nach deutlich
zunehmen
das ist noch mal die worte von florian a
dankeschön für diese einschätzungen aus
berlin ja und das war unserer live
stream zur bundespressekonferenz mit der
kanzlerin zum start eben der neuen
corona regeln viele weitere infos findet
ihr natürlich bei uns auch in der zdf-
heute- app vielen dank an euch für eure
fragen und fürs mitmachen und dann sagen
wir einen schönen tag und bis zum
nächsten mal